how does he respond to this does he say
like you know it never actually happened
he's like he just dreams every night or
something or what like if he comes out
too hard like no I'm not gay then like I
feel like the lgbtq lobby will be like
what well it's like not even a little
bit well did you see the lgbtq lobby is
mad at Bud Light for not doubling down
yeah they've lost all of their market
share and 400 million in sales Bud Light
Lost 400 million dollars in sales in the
last quarter or something like that and
the lobby doesn't care that's not market
share like market share is like their
stock drop no like they actually lost
that money in direct sales they're
laying people off they're shutting down
bottling plants the Distributors are
affected yeah they're they're saying
that they expect it not to recover well
because it'll always have that label as
the gay beer not that anything's wrong
with that it's great but that's who
their new faces though if Obama confirms
this letter then shaves Bud Light
oh could you be could you imagine if
he's the next spokesman for Bud Light
he's like I'm gay and this is why
because I drink Bud Light